[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSE HAINES: Welcome to Google.
SARAH KESSLER: Thank you
so much for having me.
JESSE HAINES: So this--
I loved reading this book.
And definitely jumped into
this book with the perception
that I think many
folks might have,
that the gig economy is
this great thing that
allows everybody to
be their own boss,
and play by their own
rules and so forth.
And I think what you have
done so powerfully here
is really kind of unpack that.
But why don't we, just
to kick things off,
start with the basics?
What is the gig economy?
SARAH KESSLER: So that is a
surprisingly controversial
question.
People will fight
about this for hours.
Because some people
think that gig economy is
only kind of apps that
give out jobs, like Uber.
Some people think
it's all freelancers.
Some people think it's
kind of this shift away
from full-time employment,
whether that be
contract workers
or temp workers,
or other things that
aren't traditional jobs.
I think it's kind of
just a buzzword used
to describe these set of
companies that came up
with this new idea
of-- well, let's say
[INAUDIBLE] was a new idea.
We can control independent
work through an app.
In the book, I was looking
at how does technology
impact this long-term trend
towards freelance workers?
JESSE HAINES: Definitely
a little bit more
controversial than you
would have thought.
So maybe let's dig in on that
technology piece a little bit.
So how have all the advances
that we've seen in technology
impacted the gigging culture?
SARAH KESSLER: So let's see.
I started getting
introduced to this topic,
and started looking at it
when I was a tech blogger,
and I was hearing three
to four startups a day
pitch me their companies.
Maybe there are three or four
of those still around today.
That was in 2010.
And I noticed this pattern of
pitch, which went something
like, hey, we've
created this app that's
going to solve unemployment.
Because in 2010, that
was still a problem.
And it's also going to make
everybody love their jobs.
It's called Uber.
It's called Uber for car
washing or it's called Uber
for brushing your teeth--
whatever.
But now, you can
just press a button.
You can get work.
Problem solved.
You're welcome.
And I think as that played
out-- and in the book,
I follow people in very
different positions
within that world, and
how it plays out for them.
But they found ways to take what
had been a totally independent,
"I'm my own business," which is
something that totally exists.
And really is that great,
work-from-the-beach situation.
But they found a way to make
it the same classification
and still give people the
responsibility of being
your own business, but
actually, in reality,
manage you a little bit.
It's also much easier
to hire a freelancer
than it's ever been before.
There are these
online platforms.
There's easy ways to search.
You can keep track of them.
Some of these
platforms have features
where, if you hire
a freelancer, you
can also watch a
video of all the hours
that they are working
for you on their desktop
to make sure that they
didn't check their email
or something while they were
supposed to be working for you.
So there are all these
things that make it easier.
And while this has been a
shift since the '70s, companies
outsourcing more and
more of their work
out to people who
aren't their employees,
I think that technology makes
it easier in more situations.
JESSE HAINES: What I
love most about the book
is that you brought us
into the gig economy
through stories of individuals
who are all interacting
in very different ways with--
participating in the gig
economy in very different ways.
So let's dig in a little bit
to some of those stories.
And I'll let you decide.
The takeaway, I
think, for me, was
that there's a lot to offer.
Some are thriving, some are not.
And there's just a lot
more nuance and challenges
in this gig economy.
So tell us about--
maybe start with
someone who's thriving.
Tell us about Curtis.
SARAH KESSLER: OK.
So Curtis is a
software programmer.
He just graduated from college.
He went to work his full-time
job for the first time,
and realized it
was super boring.
He was done with his work at
noon, and he had nothing to do.
So he watched people play
video games on the internet,
and tried to pitch projects,
but they went nowhere.
So he was extremely
frustrated and bored,
and was looking for jobs.
And ran across this
platform called
Gigster, which doles
out freelance jobs
to independent contractors
who are software developers.
And he quit his job, joined
this, and in his first month,
made $12,000.
Didn't have to go out and
find clients, or advertise,
or do any of the things
that are normally associated
with a small business.
Totally loved it.
Got to pick his own projects,
grew as an employee.
And then, ended up
leaving the gig economy
because he had built
his resume enough
where he was able to land his
dream job, which was at SpaceX.
JESSE HAINES: So that's kind of,
I think, maybe a little bit--
SARAH KESSLER: Right.
That's the happy side.
JESSE HAINES: --the
gig economy dream.
But there were a
lot of other stories
that didn't quite
turn out like that.
So tell us about another person.
SARAH KESSLER: Sure.
So Curtis's situation was
a specific, highly skilled
professional situation.
And I think a lot
of what's happened
is people who are
promoting this kind of work
for work that's not that have
taken that narrative and said,
that's what it's like for, also,
these people who are giving you
rides, or fixing your scooters,
or whatever it is that is not
highly paid, professional
work, which is not necessarily
the case.
So before Curtis quit
to join the gig economy,
he saved a year's worth
of living expenses.
He met with an accountant
to see how much he
had to save for taxes,
and what else did he do?
He bought health insurance.
So he kind of created this
social safety net for himself.
You know, if he got called
to jury duty, which he did,
and he couldn't work, he
just moved his projects
to the next week, you know?
It wasn't like he
couldn't buy groceries.
So for other people in
these situations, where,
when you're working
as a freelancer,
you don't have any protections
from any labor laws.
Not even discrimination
or sexual harassment.
You have no minimum wage.
No right to unionize,
which is a big one.
And that's a much
bigger problem if you
don't have the power of a
year's worth of savings.
So there was this other
project in rural Arkansas,
where a nonprofit
heard this pitch
about if opportunity
isn't around you,
you can just press
a button and you
can get connected
with these gigs
and have instant employment.
And they thought, we'll take
to rural Arkansas, where
the normal workforce
development thing to do
is build businesses, attract
businesses to give jobs.
But instead, we'll teach people
how to use the gig economy.
And they'll get jobs that way.
So I followed this project
for two or three years.
And the false thinking
of "we can make an app
that fixes this
problem" became very
apparent very
quickly to everyone
who was involved in it.
It works if you're a programmer
to just download an app
and use your skills.
But that's not the problem
for people who are--
40% of whom are living in
poverty in this small town.
They don't have high-speed
internet that works.
They don't have educations
that allow them to get jobs,
like social media
consultant, where
you need perfect grammar to
be able to gracefully meld
a sale into a punchy joke.
So they just ended up
applying and applying and not
getting anywhere.
And I think, at the
end of the program,
there was something like
over four years, four
people had gotten
any work, one of whom
I actually follow in this book.
And you can cut me off if I'm--
JESSE HAINES: Yeah, no, no.
I think this is interesting.
SARAH KESSLER: But the
man from the program,
who I followed in the book,
his name is Gary Foster.
And the digital job he got
was as a customer service
representative for Sears.
You remember Sears.
[LAUGHTER]
And so his relationship
to Sears was--
he would pick up
the phone, be like,
thanks for calling
customer service at Sears.
He was an independent
contractor to a small business.
And that small business had
a contract with a call center
that had a contract with Sears.
So that's a lot of
layers, to the point
where, if something
happens to him,
Sears is not going
to be like, oh, yeah.
That was our employee.
They're going to be like, I
don't know who that guy is.
He had questions
about his check,
and he was afraid
to say anything
because he knew that there
was nothing protecting him
from wrongful termination.
And then, when they required
him to take a three-week class
to train, which his instructor
had negotiated that he wouldn't
have to pay for.
Because, usually, you would
have to pay for the training
class for three weeks that you
would take in order to work.
But he wasn't making
any money, and so he
wasn't paying his bills.
There's also a
questionable flexibility
because the pitch is you
can work whenever you want.
But if you're doing something
like customer service, how
you get hours is whenever
they have hours available.
And so they release the
hours onto this platform,
and everyone scrambles
to pick them up
as quick as they can
anytime they're available.
So if that's 20 hours
this week, that's great.
It might only be four, and
you didn't get another job
because you thought you
were going to work 20.
JESSE HAINES: So I think
this rural Arkansas example
definitely highlighted
certainly a lot of the pitfalls
and challenges of
the gig economy.
But I think Terrence,
who was the guy who said,
let's give this a try.
Let's see if I can
make this gig thing
work in my small, rural hometown
that is challenged, and is
on such hard times.
Do you think there's any hope?
Did you walk away
from that saying, no,
this is just never
going to be able to--
this is great for the
Curtises of the world,
but not for small, rural
towns where there just
aren't enough jobs?
SARAH KESSLER: I think
it could be better.
The fact that we've
structured everything
around this 9:00 to 5:00 job,
there's a lot of flaws in that.
It was kind of built
for a time when
we thought an ideal
family meant a man that
goes to work all day, and a
woman who stays home and works
all day for free.
And to the extent that
that was ever the case,
that is very much
no longer the case.
And that causes-- this
idea everyone should
work on the same schedule
causes a lot of families a lot
of stress.
You have people who are going
to school or doing other things
that they want to work
less than full time.
People are living
longer and healthier.
And maybe they don't--
if they're going to have
a 60-year long career,
don't want to work full-time
for that whole thing.
So there are definitely
potentials for this.
Also, the need to work
that way, technology
is taking away a
little bit, too.
You don't have to come to
the office to get the files,
or to talk to people
you're working with.
More and more of
the country doesn't
have to go to work to
be in the assembly line.
There's a lot of potential.
It's just all of our structure
is around this 9:00 to 5:00
job.
So when that was
created, which was
a new thing at the time in
the Industrial Revolution,
coming from being distributed on
farms, we screwed up at first.
We sent children to work.
We locked people inside of
factories that might burn down.
It was bad, but then we
developed these structures--
like labor laws and
social benefits--
that supported it.
And just don't have that at
all for this kind of work.
JESSE HAINES: So let's stay
on that for a little while.
Where do you think--
the gig economy is marching on.
It's just growing.
All the data would
point to the fact
that this phenomenon is just
getting bigger and bigger.
And now, policy needs
to kind of catch up.
What are your thoughts
on some of the things
that we need in that area?
SARAH KESSLER: Sure.
So this is something that
I think is interesting.
Because when you talk
about the gig economy,
depending on your
definition, you're
talking about a
small set of people.
But here's a place,
I think, where
if you solved some
of their problems,
you would solve other
people's problems, as well.
So for instance, there's
a lot of employees
who are paying more and more
for health insurance provided
by their companies,
even, every year.
Or their retirement savings
or 401(k)s with the company
instead of pensions.
And they're accepting more
risk, and also feeling
tied to the company.
So the big idea for how to
solve the gig economy's problems
is benefits should be portable.
Either everyone should
have health insurance,
or your health insurance
shouldn't be tied to your job.
Maybe multiple employers
can pay into it.
Maybe it's housed with a
union or another entity.
And so I think that's kind
of the leading idea for how
to make things better.
And the problem is everyone can
agree that that's a good idea,
but they all mean totally
different things when
they say that it's a good
idea about who pays for it
and those kind of things.
JESSE HAINES: Yeah, yeah.
Have you seen any
interesting developments,
or any progress against any
of the ideas to support this?
SARAH KESSLER: Yeah.
There's a group of
Democrats in the House
that are campaigning
for this idea.
But again, short
on details, which
is really where it
needs to be worked out.
A union leader will
say, what we mean
is everyone will have
a $15 minimum wage.
Everyone will have
a full pension.
And then you get the other
side, which is like, great.
Companies will pay for
nothing, and good luck.
But we both support
portable benefits.
So few details on that.
One thing I think is
interesting is the idea of--
I really think that these are
structural problems that we
need to solve with policy.
But one interesting
idea, aside from that,
is having cooperatively-owned
platforms.
So if your Uber driver
owned part of the Uber app,
they would benefit from
this new efficiency
that they're creating by
participating in Uber.
And the same thing that
makes it easy for Uber
to manage freelancers
in this way
could make a co-op
a lot easier, too.
Like software scales.
If I'm going to
start a new Uber app,
I can buy a white label
solution for, like, $30 a month.
And everybody knows what a white
label solution is here, right?
Because I'm in Google.
And if I want people
to vote on everything
I'm doing in the
co-op, I don't have
to go door to door
with my ballot.
I can send them a
push notification.
So I think there's some
promise in that idea.
JESSE HAINES: Interesting.
Getting back to the book for
just a second, another story
that I thought would
be interesting to share
with the group is the
story of Christie,
who I think was able to really
benefit from the gig economy,
but not without some
tough consequences.
Can you share her story
with the folks here?
SARAH KESSLER: Sure.
So I think she's a good
example of, in some ways,
being a good thing that there's
this opportunity that exists.
But also still, at the same
time, maybe not super fair,
something we can
be too proud of.
How many of what
Mechanical Turk is?
Amazon Mechanical Turk?
Everyone?
JESSE HAINES: A lot of people.
SARAH KESSLER: OK, awesome.
So Christie, back
during the recession--
JESSE HAINES: I would
explain it anyway.
There might be some--
not all the hands on.
SARAH KESSLER: OK.
So Amazon Mechanical Turk is
this platform where companies
can post small tasks, and
then thousands of people
pick them up and do them for
maybe $0.05 or less a task.
An example might be like,
I have 1,000 products
on my e-commerce site.
Label each one every time you--
or write a description
for each one.
Every time you do
that, you win $0.05.
Or another very common
thing that happens
is, label these
images which they're
creating data for machine
learning algorithms, which I--
do I need to explain machine
learning algorithms to Google?
JESSE HAINES: I think that
maybe we're good on that.
SARAH KESSLER: I feel
like you guys got that.
All right.
Usually, I have to spend
10 minutes explaining
what that is.
This is kind of fun.
So Christie, her husband
lost his job in a factory.
She realized she
has to make money.
She's never worked outside
the home before, really.
She has no resume.
She's applied at McDonald's.
They haven't called her back.
So she logs onto
Amazon Mechanical Turk.
And because she is a genius,
makes $40,000 a year,
$0.05 at a time.
And the way that she
does this involves
all sorts of really
entrepreneurial thinking.
She set up-- there
was a forum where
people on Amazon
Mechanical Turk alert
each other of good jobs, which
are ones that you can repeat
really fast, that pay well.
And she had an alarm on her
computer that would go off--
JESSE HAINES: Crazy.
SARAH KESSLER: --if
someone posted there,
after they checked
if she was qualified
and could do the task.
And it had different levels of
alarm for how good the job was.
And she would sleep
in her office in case
the alarm went off, and
she could do this quickly.
So all sorts of
things like that.
And so she did it.
She made the ends meet.
But after a while,
you don't want
to be sleeping in your office
and jumping up for an alarm.
She developed a lot of injuries
in her wrists and shoulders,
from literally sitting
at the computer.
Most of this work is very--
you have to use a
lot of keystrokes
and a lot of mouse work, and
there's no workers compensation
insurance.
So even though her
job had hurt her,
she had to keep
working through it.
She couldn't afford the
medication, to get surgery.
So it was just, for me, this--
OK, great.
There was this opportunity.
I don't know how you would
have made this money otherwise.
But also, maybe we can
do better than this.
Yeah.
JESSE HAINES: Yeah.
A fascinating story of Christie.
Let's zoom out a little bit.
You've shared some
ideas of how you
think you could make gig work
a little bit more secure.
What about-- how is the gig
economy impacting our culture?
SARAH KESSLER:
That's interesting.
I think this break away
from directly employing
your janitor and your bus driver
and everything, that's been
in the works for a long time.
A lot of these apps that are
a part of the gig economy
are also part of the
on-demand economy.
And certainly, there's a
new immediacy with which
people expect certain things--
or certain people
expect certain things.
And then, people talk about this
surf culture in San Francisco
when they talk about
the gig economy.
JESSE HAINES: What
does that mean?
SARAH KESSLER: You have the
people who make the apps
and the people who work for
the apps, and it's become--
partly because of
this labor system,
where labor is so
cheap, and also you only
pay for exactly
how much you use,
it's never been less expensive
to have a personal driver
and someone who you can
press a button on your phone,
and they'll come do your hair.
And it almost echoes this
royalty-feudal system
that we thought was something
for historical drama.
I'm a big "Downton Abbey" fan.
JESSE HAINES: Have
you ever gigged?
SARAH KESSLER: So it depends
which definition you're using.
My book was technically a
supplemental income gig economy
assignment.
I also-- where I started
to get interested
in the worker
perspective of this
was about two years
after that startup
blog, and hearing
all these pitches
about how I'd be
working from the beach
and doing what I love
whenever I want to.
I pitched this self-serving
story to my editor
at "Fast Company,"
like, hey, why don't I
take a month off and do
this, and see how it goes?
And they said yes.
And so I spent a month
trying to beat minimum wage,
signing up for kind of--
I signed up for 30
or 40 platforms.
Everything from virtual personal
assistants and TaskRabbits
and dog walking and all of them.
I had a class on Skillshare,
and I failed miserably.
I couldn't-- I thought
it would be easier.
JESSE HAINES: You weren't
a good dog walker?
SARAH KESSLER: No.
No one hired me.
I guess I-- and I write
persuasively for a living,
so I thought my profile
was pretty nice.
I ended up--
I dissolved someone's
LLC at the Harvard Club.
I was in a proposal
dance flashmob.
JESSE HAINES: OK.
SARAH KESSLER: And I'm--
you can definitely tell which
one is not trying to make it
as a dancer in New York City.
I'm like, oh, yeah, chasse.
[LAUGHTER]
And let's see.
I did so many ridiculous things.
I cleaned out people's closets
and tutored their kids.
But it was really hard.
And that was my
first realization
of this is complicated for
me, college-educated person
with actual full-time job
who's not relying on it.
It must not be the same
story for everyone else.
And that led to this
approach of trying
to find different windows
of perspective and places
in this bigger world that
we call the gig economy.
JESSE HAINES: Fascinating.
As I mentioned, I
think one of the things
that I love about this book is
how you bring this human face
to it-- the stories.
Can you tell us a little
bit just around the writing
process?
How did you find these people?
How did you piece
together these narratives?
How did you choose who
to bring into the book,
and who to leave out?
SARAH KESSLER: Yeah.
So that was a good year,
trying to figure out.
And I was looking for
specific perspectives
that I had data around that
showed the bigger picture,
but I wanted to illustrate
by putting a face to it.
I think that it's
important to tell stories
that people can be engaged
in, and present people
that they can care about,
instead of a white paper
version.
And so I was looking for
these certain people.
Some of them, I came across
during my day-to-day reporting
because I was still working as
a reporter at "Fast Company,"
and I just stayed
in touch with them.
Curtis, I met at a digital nomad
work meetup on his first day.
And then, there
were a lot of people
who I began relationships
with, thinking that they might
be people I'd include in the
book, who I didn't end up
including, for various reasons.
Most of the people in the
book were seeking attention
for one reason or another.
Some people, their lives became
such that they really were not,
and I, for the most
part, respected that.
But it's hard.
You have to spend--
to write about
people in a way that
allows other people
to care about them,
you really have to
spend a lot of time.
So in most cases, it was years
of building relationships
and talking to people about
their entire life story,
not just this particular
little part of it.
JESSE HAINES: Yeah.
It really comes through.
Awesome.
OK.
Questions from the audience.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you very much.
You touched quite a bit
on regulation and the lack
of regulation, really.
Some of the things
that you mentioned,
like portable health
care benefits,
seem very US-specific.
I'm wondering if you've got
any insights into how countries
abroad are tackling this
because I feel like this
is an issue that a lot
of different places
are grappling with.
SARAH KESSLER: So
various things.
Some countries in-between
classification.
So in the US, you can either
be an independent contractor,
you can be an employee.
If you're an employee,
you have all the rights
and all the benefits,
and your company
has to pay all the money.
And if you're an
independent contractor,
you have none of the rights
and none of the benefits,
and your company just
has to pay you whatever
they said your wage would be.
Some companies have an
in-between category,
where if you're a
dependent contractor,
you have some rights.
So there's an in-between.
Some countries in
Africa, the gig economy
is just the economy.
Everybody's an entrepreneur, so
this whole discussion probably
seems absurd.
And then, some companies
have taken a more active role
in regulating--
saying certain
apps can't be here,
or you have to set
a minimum wage.
Actually, New York just set a
minimum wage for Uber drivers.
It's not exactly a minimum wage.
It's an equation of
what they have to make.
And that's about
all I have for that.
AUDIENCE: What amount
of responsibility
do the companies that
create these gig [INAUDIBLE]
feel they have to
their freelancers?
I think Uber gets--
which is the biggest example--
has a lot of
language about this.
But what about the people
who just start something?
Do they just think, OK, if
we build it, they will come,
and we don't have
to worry about it?
Or do they-- what's the
landscape like there?
SARAH KESSLER: How
much should they have,
or how much do they think
that they should have?
AUDIENCE: How much do you
think they should have,
in terms just of where
there are some good examples
of good guys, bad guys.
SARAH KESSLER: OK.
AUDIENCE: What's
your thought on that?
SARAH KESSLER: I would
say, a lot of times,
I think that it's
somewhat of a--
it gets away from
them, in some way.
They don't understand the effect
that this would have on people,
or that even if it's great to
be a freelancer as a software
programmer, it might
be different to be
a freelance line
cook or whatever.
I do think that
they're operating
in a system that was
fundamentally not
built for what they're doing.
And that policy allows--
the way policy is written allows
for this in-between management.
And if things are
going to make--
if we're going to make big
changes that fix this problem,
it needs to be a policy-driven
thing, and not a new app,
or a new way to buy
workers compensation
insurance for yourself because
your company has no obligation
to provide it to you.
And so I think individual
companies can really only--
they should be good actors
towards their own ecosystem,
but can't totally
fix all the problems.
AUDIENCE: From the stories
that you covered, to me,
there seemed like there
is this idea of they're
in survival mode, just
trying to make it day by day,
and figure out how--
solving short-term
life planning.
Do you get a sense that any of
the people that you followed
had a long-term perspective
of where they envisioned
themselves in 10 years,
20 years where they
worried some about the future?
To me, that just seems like
a little bit of the backlash
of this [INAUDIBLE] framework.
SARAH KESSLER: I'd say,
in the hierarchy of needs,
if you're there because
this is what you need to do,
then you think about
your money first,
and health insurance
only becomes a problem
when you get in a car accident.
And then it becomes
a big problem.
But there were people who--
the Uber driver who I follow
in the book, Abe, he had,
for a long time, been obsessed
with becoming a millionaire,
and falling for all these
get-rich-quick schemes,
which he kind of--
when Uber made this pitch, like,
you can be your own business,
and you can join this echelon
of entrepreneurs, he signed up.
And yeah, today,
he still believes
he's going to be a
millionaire, which
I found really interesting.
Because if you look
at mobility in the US,
and think about why people
join get-rich-quick schemes,
there's really--
it doesn't feel like if
you work hard, and you--
if you're not coming
from anywhere,
that you're actually
going to get ahead.
It feels like you need that.
So that was an
interesting thing.
And then, the people
who are there by choice,
I think it is a investment in
their lifestyle and future,
and where they want to be.
AUDIENCE: In all
of the people that
you followed in your
years of research,
did you come across any
particular tools that
are actually helping [INAUDIBLE]
really good resources that you
came-- that you
encountered over and over?
Whether it's around health
care, or retirement planning,
or non-payment protections
or anything like that?
The thing about the gig economy
is that it's not one industry.
It's not one job type.
So information is
very fragmented,
and even for
freelancers and giggers,
it's really hard to
find this information.
So I'm just wondering if you
found any companies, startups,
or tools out there that
stood out for [INAUDIBLE]..
SARAH KESSLER: I came across
a lot of interesting ones,
but I never came across one
that people who are working
knew about and told me about.
So I came across a lot
of interesting ideas,
but it didn't seem like
they were being really
embraced or used.
One interesting idea are savings
tools, where a big problem
is your income is variable.
You don't know how much money
you're going to make next week.
So they take a bit-- if
you're having a good week,
they take a bit of your
income, and save it.
And then, if you're having a bad
week, they pay it back to you.
So it's an attempt of
evening out the uncertainty
in the income.
But I didn't actually find
anybody who was using it.
There's attempts to
break down insurance
to make it easier to
buy as a freelancer.
But again, in the hierarchy
of immediate needs,
maybe that's not first on your
mind if you're a freelancer.
AUDIENCE: When it comes to
[INAUDIBLE],, in general,
if we look at it
more historically,
it would be more focused on
the goods than the services.
A structure [INAUDIBLE] being
put in place [INAUDIBLE]
focus on the goods production
for [INAUDIBLE] time.
This gig economy sounds,
from all the examples
you listed, really
focused to service skills
today, and only services.
We know that service is taking
a lot more importance today.
How do you foresee
some of those things
being able to be migrated
back to the goods production?
Or are we going to have
a split structure, one
for the services--
[INAUDIBLE] and
all those things--
and another one which is
going to be the archaic legacy
level things,
exploiting workers?
SARAH KESSLER: This is
an interesting question.
Because if you look at
Apple producing an iPhone,
they have something like 100
times-- something ridiculous--
of people who work on the
iPhone in different companies,
or on contract, than they
do employed in Cupertino.
So this fragmentation
of work has already
happened in the goods
side of things, in a way.
You also have temp workers
and contract workers.
There are some things
about factories which--
safety things, which
make this a difficult--
having a new workforce every
day is just not practical
But I don't know what the
split is, in terms of it
being a totally different
economy for services.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SARAH KESSLER: Sorry I
don't have a better answer.
AUDIENCE: No, you
[INAUDIBLE] the question.
I feel like, when we start
talking about those things,
we always think
about the future.
[INAUDIBLE] the
services-centric things.
But we forget that in order
for us to be at the cafeteria,
someone's actually
growing some plants.
Some people which are actually
building those chairs.
Those are not at all even
close to being thought of,
any type of those working
innovations that I know of.
And I was wondering if it's a
reflection which is happening
within those people you've met.
Or if it's totally abstracted.
SARAH KESSLER: Yeah.
I think I see--
I see-- there's, on the one
hand, the big trend, which is--
the decades' long trend of
outsourcing, which is, I
don't want to hire my janitor.
I want to hire the company
that provides my janitor.
Or I don't want to hire people
directly that work in my field.
I'm going to hire the temp
workers to work in my field.
And I think if you look at
some of these basic things,
you'll find it.
But it's just what we're
paying attention to is Uber
and this very extreme
version of that, which
is I'm employing
you for, literally,
when I get in your car
to when I leave your car.
And so it's almost
a version of that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
One of the shifts that
the gig economy brought
is that workers no longer get
training as part of their jobs.
Did you find-- how do you
find these folks reflect
on the upskilling that they
have to do all the time?
Is this something they
pursue on their own?
Do they just not pursue jobs
they're unqualified for?
How does education connect
to this very different--
SARAH KESSLER: Yeah,
that's interesting.
Because for some people, I
think it is an upskilling.
They use it to go build a resume
by doing these freelance jobs.
But on the other hand,
there's other types of work.
I don't know who
said it's not a--
it's not a sector.
It's a management strategy
is how I think of it.
So it could be any kind of work.
So some people use it
as an upskilling thing.
But then there are others,
where there's no opportunity
to really learn something new.
And if you're not
an employee that
belongs to the
company, what incentive
do they have to teach
you how to do anything
you don't already
know how to do?
I think you're seeing
a lot of companies
try to solve this problem by
offering free online classes,
or I think Salesforce,
LinkedIn, Google, and a Fiverr,
like this freelance platform,
they all offer online skills.
You can take this
class and you can show
that you have this new skill.
So the evolution of that, I
think, will be interesting.
And I don't know what
will happen to it.
JESSE HAINES: And I think
another dimension to it
is the need for
upskilling, and then
the gig economy allowing
you to have that flexibility
to work so that you
can go to school
and continue to skill up.
So there's a lot a
lot of dimensions
to that, the skilling
conversation.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I don't know if you know
the data around this,
but the takeaway I'm
getting from what I've heard
and from what I've read, is that
the gig economy, on average,
is not providing the
wages that people
think they might get by going
into it, yet it's growing.
So to what extent do you
know the data behind,
are people continuing
in these jobs?
Because-- I know there's
a lot of turnover.
But on average, are people
continuing in these jobs
because they are not finding
full-time alternatives?
To what extent are people
looking for other options,
or is it the flexibility
is giving them
enough value that it offsets
the fact that they're not
making a lot of money?
SARAH KESSLER: I
think one thing that's
interesting about the data
is a large portion of people
are doing this part-time,
or on a supplemental basis,
which, to me, suggests
unemployment is very low.
But what does the quality
of those jobs look like?
And can people actually
make ends meet on a job,
or do they have to do more?
I think it's too
soon to see data
about whether now that
unemployment is so low,
will fewer people
be freelancers?
Will fewer people be doing this?
But it's an
interesting question.
JESSE HAINES: I will throw
in that, as I was preparing
for this talk, I came across
this stat, which I almost
couldn't believe.
And I'm curious to
get your take on it.
A recent survey commissioned
by the online freelancing
platform, Upwork and
the Freelancers Union
shows that the freelance
workforce is growing
three times faster than
the overall US workforce,
and that the majority of people
will be working independently
by 2027, which is right
around the corner.
SARAH KESSLER: Yeah.
There's so much data.
It's so hard to quantify this.
JESSE HAINES: Yeah.
SARAH KESSLER: Different
government agencies
have suggested that the number
of freelancers in the US
is anywhere between 10% to 40%.
JESSE HAINES:
That's a huge delta.
SARAH KESSLER: So
Freelancers Union
is asking, have you done
freelance work this year,
which is a very different
question than the BLS
survey, which asks,
was your main job
this week independent
contractor work?
To which the person on the
other end of the phone says,
what's a main job?
What's an independent
contractor?
I don't know if I'm classified
as an independent contractor.
Can I get you to
hang up the phone?
Sure.
Yes, fine.
That's what I am.
Or no, I'm not.
So it's hard to tell.
People fight about this a lot.
What is the percentage?
And I think it's almost
a distracting question.
JESSE HAINES: Yeah.
So I think we're
going to wrap up.
I'd love to just end
on, beyond the book,
as you've been covering
the future of work, what
are some other interesting
trends that you see,
or other sort of
emerging hot topics
in this interesting conversation
about the future of work?
SARAH KESSLER: Yeah.
So we don't know, because
it's in the future, what
will happen.
But I think that how will
technology change work
is an interesting question,
just like it was 100 years ago,
and it will continue to be.
And I think the culture of
even not being in the office
is really interesting.
Maybe it will all start
to spread out more.
But I don't have a big thesis
about, the future of work
is chat bots or
anything like that.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSE HAINES: Anything
that, when you were writing
this book, surprised you?
SARAH KESSLER: I
think the thing that
surprised me is I started out
with, OK, Silicon Valley had
this idea, and made
this guess, or promise,
about what it would be.
What does that look like?
And then that-- just
how big that question
got, to the point
where you're like, OK.
Well, then, there's
this bigger trend
of work moving this
way, in general,
and risk moving to
workers, in general.
And then, the history of
work and the Industrial
Revolution, and just how much
was packed into this one story
about apps like
Uber, and how much
it touches other
than Uber, which
is what we all talk about.
Which, in a way, is great
because it brings attention
to this issue, but it's
much bigger than that.
JESSE HAINES: Great.
SARAH KESSLER: Yeah.
JESSE HAINES: Well, if
you guys can join me
in thanking Sarah Kessler
for being with us here today.
[APPLAUSE]